il est l'une des principales voix de la
russie sur la scène internationale
depuis ses 16 dernières années
né en 1950 dans la capitale russe
sergueï lavrov est issu d'une famille
arménienne
diplômé de l'institut d'état des
relations internationales de moscou à la
fin des années 1960 il va rapidement
démarré son ascension au sein de la
diplomatie soviétique sergueï lavrov
devient premier secrétaire de la mission
de l'urss aux nations unies à partir de
1981 puis devient le représentant
permanent de la russie à l'onu en 1994
il y restera dix ans pendant ces années
onusienne sergueï lavrov est décrit par
ses collègues comme un redoutable
négociateur inflexible et qui défend
coûte que coûte la position de son pays
nous réagirons de manière pragmatique
pas comme des petits garçons qui offense
et claque la porte s'enfuit de la classe
et se met à pleurer dans un coin les
relations internationales se sont
établies sur le principe de réciprocité
on a ce que l'on mérite autant de
qualités qui vont le conduire à devenir
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
la fédération de russie en 2004 à la
manoeuvre sur tous les grands dossiers à
commencer par le conflit syrien
après avoir obtenu le démantèlement de
l'armement chimiques de damas en 2013 il
accuse à plusieurs reprises l'occident
de soutenir des groupes terroristes
nous sommes très préoccupés par la façon
dont certains de nos partenaires
occidentaux ont changé leur
compréhension même de la terreur ils
disent que le terrorisme en syrie doit
être arrêté mais cela est impossible
temps qu'assad est au pouvoir
cela signifie qu'ils écartent le
principe fondamental et universel que le
terrorisme est totalement injustifiable
en fait ils essaient de trouver des
excuses aux terroristes et de lancer des
ultimatums
une stratégie qui fait le jeu des
partisans du terrorisme en syrie sergueï
lavrov est également l'un des principaux
artisans de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien signé en 2015 un texte qu'il
défend bec et ongles
malgré le retrait américain de l'accord
en 2018 nos positions sur la plupart des
questions qu un si doux sont très
proches
bien entendu la situation autour du plan
d'action global commun sur la résolution
du programme nucléaire iranien était au
centre de la discussion mais nous avons
réaffirmé notre ferme engagement à
maintenir cet accord crucial qui a été
approuvée par une résolution du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies les
tensions avec les occidentaux le conduit
s'est également a accusé l'otan de
restaurer une atmosphère de guerre
froide avec la russie souveraineté rejet
de l'ingérence dans les affaires des
autres et à égalité des peuples respect
mutuel la russie a toujours respecter
ces principes dans ses relations
internationales et continuera de les
défendre au cours des 25 dernières
années notre pays malgré les difficultés
a fait sa part du contrat concernant
l'élimination du patrimoine de la guerre
froide et a fait beaucoup pour renforcer
la confiance et la compréhension dans la
zone euro atlantique et dans le monde
sergueï lavrov reste donc à son poste
une continuité qui devrait permettre à
la russie de peser dans les nombreux
dossiers cruciaux pour l'avenir de la
planète